in the past  i thought he told me everything is there  anything else i need to know  because i don't want to wake up one  morning and see another video or  you in bed with her or god but  but this time around i'm not gonna let  it go  i don't think i could be married to  someone that lies to me  you sit here  i asked you before we got married was  there anything else  and then this new video pops up  i don't know it looked like you were  looking at the camera and you guys were  laughing and joking around in the bed  like doing sex positions and she was  like moaning i know  her  but how did you get in that position how  did you get in her room and  well i don't understand like why can't  you just be open  did she want you did she there's no need  to tell you  florian why did you go there like why  did you do that  i still don't have the answers to that i  don't feel good i'm talking from this  i'm still a lot  well i don't understand like why can't  you just be open  [Music]  you